so I think that an example where the
finance community has previously treated
money and finance as a math equation or
math game right CD it was like cap em
and whack and DCF and all these
valuation models like well so if we go
to the CD O's right you recently said
you know stable coins are basically the
CEOs of crypto explain what you mean by
that right so I think here's the problem
is the crypto community has latched on
we tend to latch on to narratives and
then we work through a narrative for six
to nine months right so the narrative
that started developing last year was oh
the reason that people don't want to
invest in crypto is because it's too
volatile and moving into and out of fiat
is too difficult and so people started
saying why don't we create this concept
of a stable coin and we've already seen
iterations of it I think part of the
impetus frankly was the fact that tether
was so successful and so widely adopted
that it kind of shocked everyone but I
think the problem with stable coins now
and now every platform is launching
their own stable coin right so you have
collateral back stable coins like tether
or like digits which is backed by gold
then you have collateralized stable
coins that things like maker or Haven
that rely on kind of a two coin system
where you can redeem or create the
stable coin through secondary mechanism
and then you have the idea of a
programmatic quote-unquote decentralized
almost decentralized Bank structure or
sovereign issuance structure where
people are issuing assets then there's
complex governance structure and I think
the problem is this is number one the
thesis as to why Stephan stable coins in
need to exist has not been proven true
right it's same problem with that
protocol it's like that caught on and
then we saw billions of dollars of
financing flow into nonsensical
protocols because everyone was so
addicted to this idea of fad protocols
I think we've the same narrative with
stable coins where we're creating this
false narrative in our minds because at
first blush it makes sense so it's like
if a then B therefore C must be true and
we know that's not always true so what I
think we're doing is we're number one
we're financing stable coins through
an investment structure that doesn't
align incentives right so going to an
investor and saying hey if you buy this
asset early on then you're gonna get to
participate in value creation or in the
flow of payments through this network
like that doesn't really work no one's
paying the Fed to create colors
something that's a weird structure and I
think again what we're doing is we're
creating all of this systemic risk right
because now we have stable coins on
protocols and then on top of the stable
coins there are more coins like it's
coins all the way down point going Quinn
Quinn Quinn and the thing is at some
point we stopped being able to untangle
how any of this works and the degree of
systemic risk and the system is already
so incredibly high you think about the
fact that Zappo custody is 10% or more
of the world's big coin you think about
the fact that coin base holds a lot of
crypto assets you think about the fact
that by Nance probably hosts 50% of
traded volume and all assets right we
already have a lot of systemic risk we
don't need to layer in fifty to a
hundred to 150 different stable coins
that are all abstractions of themselves
with no governance structure no audit
ability and frankly like no one has the
appetite to monitor this [ __ ] either yep
unnecessary